I think at this point you guys probably
know I'm big on this free speech thing
I'm a firm believer that you can say
absolutely anything you want period that
doesn't mean there won't be consequences
for what you say but you have the right
to say what you want by the same token
others have the right to rebut your free
speech by exercising theirs
this is how good ideas win not by
stifling bad speech but by beating it
with better ideas as I've mentioned many
times in America right this very moment
I'm not that concern that the government
is coming for my free speech you can say
pretty much anything you want about the
government without fear and in many
cases you'll look cool for fighting the
power there are instances like Edward
Snowden and the CIA leaks where it seems
people are being persecuted for speech
but really those consequences are for
exposing state secrets however what I
fear in America is that we are taking
away speech from ourselves and we are
doing it in a plethora of ways you guys
all know about the safe spaces and the
trigger warnings on college campuses
which are designed to shield young
people from speech which might scare
them now authors with controversial
ideas are de platformed and speakers who
dare bring up a contrarian thought are
shouted down it's not just colleges
though we also have protesters blocking
roads to political rallies because they
don't like what might be said before it
actually is throwing the overuse of the
words like racist bigoted homophobic
sexist and you have a toxic mess
designed to shut down any important and
honest discussion in other countries the
threat to free speech is much worse than
we have it here America has plenty of
so-called allies who don't respect free
speech in a myriad of ways many Islamic
countries have laws against blasphemy
and apostasy meaning you can be put in
jail or even killed for mocking God or
leaving religion add the oppression of
women minorities gays and others into
the mix and you have entire societies
that not only don't have freedom of
speech but are actively trying to
control what their citizens think and
how
they act we often think that the most
backwards country is related to free
speech and these intolerant ideas are in
the Middle East but often that's not the
case my guest this week is Amos Yee Amos
is a seventeen year old from Singapore
who is an atheist and free speech
advocate
mo shares his thoughts about government
religion and more right here on YouTube
for the entire world to see Amos cotta
my radar just a couple days ago when I
started getting dozens of tweets asking
me to help him after he was arrested due
to Singapore's blasphemy laws at this
very moment he's out on $5,000 bail and
awaiting trial in Singapore he faces
five counts of wounding the religious
feelings of Muslims and one count of
wounding the religious feelings of
Christians if convicted he faces up to
three years in prison
I've caught up on some of Amos as videos
and this is a guy who pulls absolutely
no punches I've seen videos of him
mocking and licking the Koran I've seen
him humping the Bible and plenty of
other stuff he's mocking others ideas
with ideas of his own he isn't calling
for harm to a person or group of people
he's in fact doing the most human thing
you can do which is thinking for
yourself as ayaan Hirsi Ali says if you
are for minorities you must be for
minorities within those minorities this
is the perfect example of that if you
really are for atheists or free thinkers
then you must be for the brave ones who
mock the very institutions which would
have them jailed or killed
you can't just be for ideas when it's
safe you have to be for ideas when it's
your own life on the line Amos is not
only a living example of that concept
but he's also putting it all out on
YouTube for the world to see if he's
brave enough to do that then the rest of
us have a duty to use our free speech to
amplify his message if we're afraid to
do that then it's our speech the
authoritarians will come for next
my guest this week is a 17 year old from
Singapore who makes YouTube videos about
atheism and free speech and is now
paying the price for it
Amos Yee welcome to the Reuben report
hey Reuben glad to be on the show
alright so first we have to thank the
Twitter warriors for connecting us
because I was trying this weekend
Memorial Day weekend to get off Twitter
pretty much but I was slammed with a
zillion people saying free Amos Yee
you've got to talk to em OC so for
people that know nothing about you that
have never seen your videos don't know
who you are don't know why I'm talking
about you who the hell is a MOSI what
eles aim is a well I'm becoming pretty
relevant so um who the hell well
currently I'm being charged for my anti
religious videos one call responding to
calm budget of Christians and the utter
call refuting Islam with their own Quran
both of them extremely past powerful
extremely masterful works I haven't seen
any religious videos better objectively
speaking cuz I've watched many atheist
videos and haven't seen any better
anything better so totally objective
I made the greatest anti-christian and
anti-islam video and then so but
unfortunately I made it fortunately or
unfortunately that really depends I made
it in the country called Singapore which
is a complete totalitarian dictatorship
state but fortunately it says the
internet so I posted it online and
non-being charge for it yeah okay so
there's a lot there so first off for
people that haven't seen your videos and
truth is I didn't know who you were
until a couple days ago but I have I
have watched your videos now yeah you
like I do like them you're you're funny
you're edgy you clearly don't mind
putting your thoughts out there and
that's what all this whole show is about
that concept but you do some
intentionally inflammatory stuff I've
seen you licking a Koran I've seen you
humping a Bible when did you decide that
this was the route you wanted to go when
did I decide that the roof was um okay
why did I do that well the reason
okay I'm gonna use now somewhat deem
with that somewhat theme now when I use
the phrase somewhat deem is basically my
opinion it's just that I'm gonna use
that phrase now so that I will you know
not be charged for it and sing for it
because you know I use somewhat dim I'm
just saying in fact and they can't
charge me for it hopefully I hope I
don't get tried for a show okay
some would deem that Amos did it because
that's funny because people most of the
time on YouTube from the Atheist videos
that I've seen from like you know the
amazing 80s and count of dusty like
those are my favorite guest youtubers
they make points and they do it funny
but they don't go they didn't MIT yeah
so they basically taught me you know the
points of atheism but they never do it
in like a completely filthy Frankish
over-the-top funny way before so I want
to do that I want to make something new
like that and nobody ever like condensed
all of those [ __ ] of the Christians
and condensed all the [ __ ] of Islam
and then formed it into one home video
before and then made it you know just
really easy to see so I wanted to do
that which is why I made those videos
okay so some people who deem that's what
you've done I got it so when some people
would deem Ya Ya or may not be my
intention got it wow you you're you
should be a lawyer also I think um when
when did you decide you were an atheist
cuz you're pretty young when did I
decide I was yeah um around the time
when I was fifteen years old because
there's because I was once a Catholic
and there was this thing called
confirmation you know I I don't even
know what that is anymore but apparently
is this big thing where okay once you
have confirmation then you're I don't
know more of a Catholic or something I'm
not even sure so because of that I have
to think okay what this confirmation
really means what I started to actually
think that topic instead of just
mindlessly going to church every Sunday
which is what I did before so after that
um after that so then after that the
main factor was the big turning point
was when I watched the amazing atheist
videos which is what I considered to be
like the second best youtuber all-time
really influential somebody should
nominate him for god damn Nobel Prize
so 15 you you real
this confirmation thing you think okay
I'm not into religion but what was the
move from okay I don't believe in it I
have to go ahead and mock it um that was
okay after that confirmation got
enlightened by amazing atheist videos
then okay that was that became an
atheist became cool became rational
became logical I'm a better person I
think after that I um went okay after
that stuff happened and I decided I want
it to be a content creator and I decided
a school wasn't for me so I dropped out
of school didn't continue school don't
think a degree is helpful at all and
then continued helping the world with
all my with a bashing religion promoting
philosophy and all that good stuff
because I think you don't have religion
some people some people would deem that
Amos thinks that if you bash religion
exactly what like what that professor of
the Iran is the leader of that Iran is
that you say no religion no faith means
more rationality more logic means more
philosophy more science means better
world and I think it's universally
considered that if you have more
innovation and more you know and evolved
madessa human species is considered good
so that's our that's what I'm working
for
go us yeah so would you deem all
religions equally as ridiculous now
obviously I'm guessing you know
Christianity a little bit more because
that's you grew up Christian right but
do you think they're all equally silly
or nonsensical or the lack of truthiness
or any of that yeah some people would
deem that Krishi
okay Christianity is I guess in history
because as long history that is far
worse and you've done more atrocities in
our modern age Islam is the worst thing
which is why when I bashed now now
Christianity basically got destroyed by
the atheists essentially which is really
great so they don't have as much balls
anymore but Islam you know there's still
people are still scared of them so then
I made the first impact of video right
and and I some people deem that Amos
[ __ ] them hard in the ass
Buddhism school Buddhism Buddhism isn't
even a religion people misconstrue and
think that's a religion but even a
Buddha himself he said that you know
don't treat as a religion treat as a
philosophy so Buddhism is the better
best religion yeah it's a philosophy yet
so you see the difference between a
religion with dogma and ideas that you
have to believe in that are improvable
and Buddhism which is more it's more of
a spiritual path it's not necessarily
asking you to believe in things that
aren't provable right I mean I think
there's some element of that I'm not a
Buddhist scholar yeah there's something
some yeah yeah there's some elements of
it which is like you know karma and
stuff which is essentially a much more
like some people deem much more fake
aspect or than I guess but yeah yeah
that's where it like becomes really lame
the Karma and the redemption thing that
is the stuff which I don't believe in
but uh but Buddhism day they basically
advocate in warm do you like the good
stuff in the philosophy so yeah Buddhism
is the best religion it's not a religion
which is why it's the best yeah all
right so let's let's back up a little
bit so you dropped out of school to
become a youtuber that's pretty much
every kid in America's dream I mean what
what did your parents say what do how do
you make a dime I mean how do you how
are you living yeah absolutely
um um astounded stunned wanted to disown
me completely disgusted with me mom kept
on arguing with me every day but you
know you just gotta have balls and you
just got to be like I want to fulfill my
dreams and this is completely idealistic
and stupid but I'm gonna do it and okay
it's not stupid because I think there
was an underlying logic to it and that
was like I watched many videos and I
basically I knew the YouTube landscape
and I was like had ideas in my head and
I was like these ideas are far better
than all of them
I'm like I'm like amazing atheist he
makes a completely excellent videos but
I have ideas that are much cooler in my
presentation I can do it far better
actually so I'm like I'm gonna do that
and I'm pretty sure that if I do it long
enough I'll have a following and I was
right so yeah now I make enough to just
barely survive but uh yeah excellent
so you're surviving on your YouTube Rev
is that right yeah just
Adson for now we're gonna start try
starting the patreon yeah people they
want to donate you know just like to be
cool and stuff you know just I have like
my bank account in many of the videos
description I would start off like a
PayPal and patreon but I'm below 18 so
they block my account so right there was
the ones like a crowdfunding and
literally like my PayPal there's like
thousands of dollars inside which I
can't [ __ ] take so jeez disgusting
pieces of [ __ ] yeah alright so let's
talk a little bit about what's going on
in Singapore itself because I don't
think people at least in America we
don't talk about Singapore that often I
don't know that people really understand
what the government is or what level of
freedom of speech you have etc etc can
you lay out some of that stuff Singapore
is the worst country in the world in my
opinion it's a completely totalitarian
dictatorship it control the entire
mainstream media and it's and but the
reason why you distinct like Singapore
from North Korea the reason why it's
much worse is because it's way more
insidious people don't know the
atrocities that's happening in Singapore
people and Singapore is really able to
fool all foreigners to think that
Singapore's democratic Singapore's
peaceful and harmonious and they still
come in work with Singapore so as to
increase their goddamn GDP what is bad
is that Singapore you know it doesn't
have the kind of like torture where it's
like you know flogging or you know
putting them in concentration camps or
selling human organs but it's more of a
psychological torture where you just
dull the mind you keep them in fear
people you know people usually think
that if you're angry we'll go out and
ride and protest on the streets but
Singaporeans are angry Singaporeans are
not peaceful but they still but
Singaporeans are not peaceful door angry
but the government does their mind so
[ __ ] bad that they're basically they
don't have any goddamn passion to do
anything so it's basically it you know
it just
manifests itself as depression race
everybody's depressed everybody's horrid
[ __ ] disgusting country my country
[ __ ] Riven so where did you get the
balls to tell me what you do was that
your mom that just walked by uh oh yeah
yeah she all right all right now I know
we have clearance from mom then so
that's good okay yes go and ask oh don't
worry she sees all into this right
I think yeah so where'd you get the
balls to do this so if you come from a
society with that level of control and
your stuff is so intentionally
over-the-top how did that moment happen
the big guy is [ __ ] TJ Kerr the
amazing atheist he essentially taught me
the importance of ideas and the
importance of thinking rationally and
then okay people might disagree with you
people might say you're horrible but
there's an importance to do this to you
know give your ideas that will [ __ ]
help out society and and that's what and
so then I just stretched it further
because you know I just spent lots you
know fear is among us even Americans
thank God a my freedom of speech but
they're still scared that you know Islam
is gonna condemn in awe of that which is
why they don't you know you know
actually made an Islam video that's as
balls he has mine the reason why but I
felt the importance to liberate myself
from fear so hours and hours just
thinking I gotta have balls I gotta have
balls I gotta literally just walking
around pacing in my house thinking gotta
have balls got to have balls and so much
balls that even I mean this I mean the
videos that I made it's it's it's risque
even for American standards the fact
that I'm doing it in Singapore where
yeah [ __ ] illegal and that's a person
who's really ahead of his time sir
and very humble very humble also so
that's very important really in the
world Ruben yeah there you go
all right so um tell me about the legal
situation you're in so right now
last I heard you're out on $5,000 bail
is that right yep posted by my dear mom
okay so what what were you actually
charged with one um five charges were
for Islam one charge for bashing
Christianity yeah that does essentially
it yeah yes what's the what's the
penalty for that up to three years in
prison
opposite tree yes up to three years in
prison is absolutely horrible then the
main the main ones which I'm gonna get
like the highest penalties for I mean
like they're all spread out over the
place in terms of like comments for blog
posts and videos and all of that but the
main ones that I'm gonna be charged for
are D Krish is the greatest anti
Christian video of all time the greatest
Islam
Valentine but you guys should watch on
YouTube you beat your left yeah um yeah
but some people deem that this is
completely politically motivated because
essentially what the government did was
they check the like and dislike because
this essentially mode it's publicly
motive you have to understand it I was
in jail before for um mocking the
dictator
Lee Kuan Yew right was already I already
did my time of like 55 days in prison
and they tried to so really I'm like I'm
political threat so you want to try to
find as many ways to take me down as
possible but the fact is they do not
want to charge me for bashing
politicians because that's frowned upon
by foreigners but right now since
everyone's sucking Islam's dick they
charge me for that thinking that the
mainstream media's and other people
overseas we're not [ __ ] talk about it
which they're right the mainstream media
has not done that because they want to
suck Islam's dick certainty attack
afterwards so who do you then get to
have a hot lunch following the content
producer the goddamn youtubers so yeah
so I must be some kind of idiot for
doing this interview apparently no
you're brilliant Ruben that's the thing
that's why we're on the show yeah thank
you thank you so you were in jail for 55
days
what is so without a children or an
adolescent jail what's it like being in
a jail in Singapore for a kid uh okay
yeah he's - I mean you're right like you
were and he wasn't you were in with the
general population were you there it's
[ __ ]
some people would deem it's [ __ ] up
because they charge me as an adult even
though I'm below 18 I'm not even sure
about that even Amnesty International
who spoke up against me in the UN they
said I was a child and demanded the
release of me from jail but the
Singapore government being the ruthless
[ __ ] that they are just didn't do it
I was sent to jail and of course it was
absolutely it was absolutely horrible
there are many times when I even said I
want to commit suicide and didn't eat
for a couple of days it's in a cell with
a bunch of goddamn yeah it's an in a
Cell all you have is like
yeah it's just there's a seat there's
there's a CCTV on it um your half yeah
um it's a [ __ ] cell I don't know I
don't know why I have to explain it you
don't have the internet you don't
activities all you do just sit in the
[ __ ] cell knocking you're selling if
you're lucky enough you can get some
goddamn books from your parents it's a
[ __ ] cell room it's horrible so I get
the sense that you're really fearless I
mean that's the one thing that's very
clear to me here you've been through
this already you've put your your ass on
the line and you're about to do it again
do you have any fear about any of this
what what could happen to you any fear
OD Anders definitely fear after you get
going go you overcome it and then you
strategize and find ways to work around
the system and help you know navigate
the area so yeah definitely there's fear
definitely there's anger and all those
negative emotions the thing is you
overcome you overcome those negative
emotions and then after that you create
even more good and big stuff so yeah and
that's essentially it just fear but
don't come in and then you create better
stops up to give her CV for Vendetta
the movie V for Vendetta yeah P for
Vendetta yeah when you were saying that
it reminded me of the moment where he
had to break her by putting her in the
cell and then after that she was totally
free that's sort of where I get where
you're coming from oh yeah exactly
you're totally free and then you know
the system more and then you have more
balls to do even better things I think
right now to try to break me even more
you know they might start to even cane
me with like the goddamn metal strips
it's [ __ ] horrible harness it I've
heard people lose their fertility
because of that so who knows I think are
gonna lose they're gonna do horrible
things to me but uh I don't know if it's
bravery in great intelligence above the
time or just insanity but I'm playing a
game Rueben so keep at it buddy keep at
it yeah I'm with you so okay so you go
to this pretrial thing a couple days ago
in as we said you're out on the the
$5,000 bail what was it like in court I
mean are they saying to you just stop
this and we'll we'll get rid of the
charges like do they want you just to
stop right now or this is happening no
matter what you do now this is happening
no matter what we do in fact some people
would deem that basically this was all
planned out all along like because what
do I put it because you see that's the
thing they don't want to admit in the
goddamn mainstream media but essentially
all the judges and the judges is linked
to the government and the judge
essentially has to you know tell people
tell the police when to charge me or not
they get to decide basically when to
charge me and when not to charge me so
wait oh yeah before that I didn't
explain the like dislike ratio
essentially what they why it is
politically motivated is because they
looked at all if you looked I basically
made a blog post where essentially I put
down the stuff that I was charged for
and stuff that I wasn't charged for and
the stuff that I was trying for the
dislike ratio was completely huge until
logic came along and asked all those 80s
youtubers up dumb and now it's much more
so maybe they might drop the charges
after that they won't but yeah the stuff
that wasn't that they didn't charge me
for was all was all it was either the
like ratio was high because it was
something popular or it was mainly like
political like there was one blog post
for example when I made the comment [ __ ]
Islam and Allah doesn't exist I mean
they charge me for saying [ __ ] Allah in
one video just one quote and he goddamn
charged me for that word so that quote
where I talked about this person called
Calvin Chang that quote should have
gotten me charged but they didn't you
know why because that was a mean quote
and and where the guy was a PAP dog PAP
is that people who run my country a PAP
dog who basically said that the right
thing to do to stop Islam is to kill all
of the killers he is the ISIS children
and that's a bad quote so if I if they
charge me for that it will raise
awareness to that court and say why
didn't they charge him for that quote
and then it wouldn't make it seem like
it was politically motivated all of that
and they don't want to do that anymore
well I'm a sly [ __ ] so yeah man
you're you're working at many levels
there what is the law related to freedom
of speech in Singapore right because we
have we have the
so here in America the government can't
take away your freedom of speech but you
said it before it seems like we're doing
it to ourselves these days in America
where we're picking topics that we don't
talk about but what are there any laws
related to freedom speech and Singapore
yes some people would say that the
constitute yeah there is a constitution
in Singapore which claims that there is
freedom of speech but it's our article
14 but in that Constitution itself it
then says class two it then says oh we
have freedom speech but there are some
restrictions to freedom speech even if
it you know breaks the public harmony or
the peace or is provocative or whatever
and that completely defeats the [ __ ]
purpose of freedom speech that in fact
that is in [ __ ] freedom of speech
anymore so the reason why we have that
constitution which claims that there's
free no speech is to for [ __ ]
foreigners into thinking that we are
democratic and that because you know
totalitarian North Korean is communist
[ __ ] or no like [ __ ]
democratic [ __ ] oh the world
like and that's the thing America you
guys Canada America Melbourne whatever
the [ __ ] you guys have freedom of speech
but your politicians aren't able to
articulate what actually freedom speech
is which is why the Singapore government
is able to manipulate it in that way
because essentially what freedom of
speech is is I haven't seen anybody
articulate this before so you're gonna
get exclusive but yeah but I mean the
central aspect of freedom speech really
is immunity from the law even if you
piss people off with your words even if
I specifically make a comment some
people deep even if I specifically make
a comment that okay Lisa and long which
is the current dictator our country
rapes children every day or I tell
people to murder every Christian or
[ __ ] Muslim in the world so that
atheism can rise I should not be charged
for it that is freedom speech right so I
guess I guess some people would say if
you were to say the latter thing which
is you know I want to murder all these
peoples or a theater can rise then
there's sort of a direct threat so I
guess there's a little bit of a gray
area there but but you're more of an
salutis do you think no matter what even
if you think it's the director yeah even
if this is like a direct threat why I
say that because that's thing I tell you
to kill all those Christian
[ __ ] I'm not I don't want to do
that by the way that's that's not a good
way to spread change but I tell you kill
all those Christian and Isis
[ __ ] somewhat deep but but um
but then you go out and kill somebody
and you cause a riot
it's your responsibility that you listen
to my words and act upon it it's not my
responsibility
right so is so if I cost so in my words
causes people to create a riot that's
their responsibility they go to jail I
don't I shouldn't be charged for that
right so you're making the distinction
obviously between words and actions so
if there was somebody look I've seen a
couple videos where people that don't
like you have you know attacked you in a
mall and I saw you got somehow somebody
grabbed you in a store and in front of a
lot of people that just kind of watched
it happens country so if there was
somebody right now that was watching
your videos that lived down the block
from you and then they started telling
people oh kill a mostly kill aimlessly
you're saying you would be you would
actually be for their right to say that
but but you would be against obviously
the person that would come to kill you
exactly don't charge the person who says
kill Amos each other people actually
kills Amos please don't kill Amos II
defi you have to make that qualification
there yeah okay so so what's next so
you're out now when is the next trial
what can people do to help awareness I
think we're doing a little something
here but what can we do
what can you guys do the biggest things
you can do is just spread the word
hashtag Freeman
Amos II make videos make blogpost say
write your feelings about it and share
my videos my videos are great really
great
uh language really I don't be [ __ ]
arrogant but really it they're great no
it's not even being Aaron it's just
stating facts they're great so share my
videos especially yeah say just Freddy
awareness and I don't know maybe if you
guys start campaigns start Facebook
pages whatever you guys know the
platforms to spread awareness so do that
on the internet and if you know people
like a much more um you know
kind of action I don't know maybe make
speeches or protest on the streets or
something in front of the Singaporean
Embassy which is what the Hong Kong
people and Taiwanese people did it
before before that when I was sent to
jail now now now I found out that the
goddamn the Singapore the Hong Kong I
think Taiwan people they're not unto me
all the NGOs and the human rights and
the activists who talked who spoke up to
me before they don't want to speak up
with me anymore because you see that's
the thing
before that I was charged for it was
very blatantly obvious that I was sent
to jail because of because there was a
political agenda because I mocked Lee
Kuan Yew but I add a little Christian
quote in between that's why it gave the
government reason for them to charge me
mm-hmm but but mock dictator it's
alright but not religion oh then you're
being too rude and because of that then
now popularity is all-time low in
Singapore nobody likes me insane for
it's a helpful out there I go out I get
attacked you saw the footage Ruben so
yeah which is why I Jorge why I was like
really depressing I'm like oh my gosh
I'm gonna lose I'm gonna go to jail
nobody's gonna talk about it then logic
came along then dusty came along and you
came along so we're gonna [ __ ] the
government yes harder alright so we know
all about the the videos of people
attacking you you just said your your
popularity is at an all-time low in
Singapore but I'm guessing that in a
society that's as repressed and
oppressed as you described it that
there's probably a lot of people who
actually are rooting for you do you get
people coming up to you privately or
sending you messages or tweets or
whatever from Singapore that are
secretly trying to push you along and
happy about what you're doing rarely
rarely now right now rarely no no that's
essentially it really all-time low
nobody dares to say anything good they
say something good about me it's I'm
popular and you know there's really lots
of peer pressure and I think that's the
same thing in every kind of society you
know you go to all the goddamn Facebook
sites like all Singapore stuff or you
know oh you know all Singapore stuff or
like the independent and you know all of
them where like singing there's a huge
scene for an audience and basically
whenever my news comes up they just bash
me you just bash me and nobody wants to
say anything good about me even though
they
like me so yeah it's just unpopular
saying stuff that's good about me so
both privately and publicly not much
from saying yeah when I see huh it's
pretty sad so if you could get out right
this moment I mean if you had a golden
ticket right this second would you want
to leave what I want to leave um I'm not
gonna tell you because there are derp
derp I'm not gonna say because that
might dictate the judge's decision some
would deem somebody huh but uh yeah I'm
not gonna say because that would dictate
the government's decision and basically
they're gonna do the things that
opposite from my from what I want but
you see that's the thing if I go if I go
overseas and then I leave the country
right now I can continue making
anti-religious videos and then continue
continuing the atheist revolution and
you know be free and obviously not go to
a cell which is [ __ ] horrible but if
I go to a cell not to say that I won't
get any attention if I'm not in a
[ __ ] cell I'm still interesting
regardless you know but um if I'm put
into a cell it there's much more
awareness because you know oh my god
somebody's sent to a cell somebody is
you know put in prison there's much more
of an incentive for people to talk about
it give protests you know you know make
raise awareness all that good stuff so
that's the thing
what are they kill me put me in a Cell
let me go immediately
I don't wait they're [ __ ] so I'm
winning Ruben I'm ready okay that's my
such an advantageous position nobody in
Singapore has ever been that
advantageous before every opposition
politicians fail because they're never
in such an advantageous position as me
so you can try Singapore Rubick you can
kill a man but you can't kill an idea I
think that's what you're saying you can
never kill an idea Ruben ideas live on
Megan Fox's tips now yeah um so what do
you think is gonna happen if you if you
had to just guess so when are you going
back I was trying to figure that out
when's the next day the next trial day
or the next day in court
oh um um in two weeks they're still
gonna be a pre trial which is like yeah
after that like in a few more weeks
later there's gonna be trouble so gonna
be stretched out for about I don't know
a few months before I get my sentence
and get sent to jail I'm pretty sure
that I'll be sent to jail
but are they sure are they saying to you
if you retract some of this or if you
take the videos down or bla bla bla that
will let you go is there any like is
there any negotiation like what are they
trying to do negotiation is we're gonna
charge you against sentence you weren't
gonna prove to everybody that you're a
[ __ ] horrible person because you see
that's the thing
PAP has been ruling the country for
goddamn 50 years and they just got their
mandate you just got 70 percent of the
goddamn vote in goddamn Singapore which
is absolutely horrible and the first
year after they get their goddamn
mandate is when they have all the [ __ ]
atrocities you know they're I mean right
now they're they're charging their they
just give a goddamn death sentence to
this guy called ko JA Bing and
everybody's goddamn [ __ ] you know
shocked and then right now there there's
this thing called there's this
ridiculous thing where a day before the
time when you vote called cooling off
day you can't goddamn write any articles
online which might distinct the you know
differentiated vote even though the
[ __ ] mainstream media can and then
these opposition people Roy young and
kill so long they're being charged for
that right now
they're being sent to jail they're the
police are raiding their [ __ ] house
this is the time the first year after
the goddamn Singapore government gets
the mandate is when they do all these
atrocious [ __ ] things so this is it
yeah so yeah that's the other [ __ ]
horrible and then which is why it's a
good time to play the game they're doing
all these atrocities they decided to
charge me after you get their [ __ ]
mandate so they want to play hard I'm
gonna [ __ ] play harder we're gonna
make the [ __ ] world explode rubens
okay let's give a little credit to your
mom she's walked back and forth a couple
times so we knew when she finds out
about all this stuff and right now she
hears you in the other room and you're
passionate and you're going on about all
this stuff she she still I know I'm sure
that your mom doesn't want you to be in
jail so what are the discussions with
you guys like does she say she just says
do whatever you want is there any level
of Tony downer of course she tries to
urge me to tone it down she tried to
urge me cuz she thinks she's like all
other people she's like oh no you know
don't be rude don't be offensive get
your points across people listen to you
more and you know that
that kind of thing you know cuz you know
she's a goddamn she's an Asian mom you
know that's the thing but but before
that she was just like yeah she was just
like disappointed pissed off now she is
really being like I don't know kind of
like uh activist we're saying you know
free Amos II III disagree with this
approach but you should not send him to
jail for it so that's the good thing
about my mom this yeah
and concerning the [ __ ] approach of
being vulgar and stuff yeah people make
the argument okay if you tone down to
volva language and all of that uh more
people would support you and you'll get
a bigger audience more people take you
seriously I don't think so actually
because you see you lose a huge portion
of audience when you use bubble language
but right now we're in the Internet age
where essentially vulgar language and
they all rain like top youtubers
PewDiePie and whoever they're all using
vulgar language not to say that
PewDiePie is good he [ __ ] sucks but
yeah basically language yeah you really
do fight the power it's one thing to
fight the state and fight religion but
to fight booty by that's big not beauty
535 shot PewDiePie um he's gonna be
forgotten in like a few years you know
Beauty eyes shop PD Python um but
anyways you gain okay you gain a much
larger audience with the whole with
using vulgar language very eloquently
and skillfully so the amount I gain I
think for now is yeah it's much more in
the amount I lose so we're supposed to
still continue to do it but things that
create a huge range I mean video called
how to destroy Singapore government
where it's essentially it's less vulgar
it's much more putting points across and
I make the greatest anti-christian video
where it's essentially vulgar as hell
you know funny [ __ ] like it's ah it's
great so yeah so yeah I make the whole
spectrum I gain a whole spectrum of the
audience you know sometimes I make a new
video or people don't like me out and
people like me and that's what makes
relationships good Ruben you piss them
off they like you again deep fist events
that's what makes life fun movie yeah I
mean that's what it's all about right
like do what you think you should do and
you know people like me have to help
defend people like you and amplify your
voice so I hope that's what we did here
do you you have a closing statement I
know there's you don't hold anything
back I feel like you made it may not
even have anything left
what closing statement you got a closing
statement for me
the government let's destroy him Lisa
and long that's the main target that's
the guy is essentially he dictates all
the laws in Singapore let's bash him out
that's [ __ ] bash that [ __ ] up
he's the one that's charging me
he's the ones that's [ __ ] causing all
of this he's the one that's imprisoning
atheists in Singapore he's the one
that's causing the worst country in the
world let's destroy him let's advocate
for goddamn philosophy and signs and all
that good freedom speech stuff man don't
us listen you absolutely have an ally in
me I promise you that it's hashtags save
a mozi free Amos
it's nice take free a mozi I'm starting
another hashtag for you there you go and
just remind we're gonna put the links
down below but remind everyone where
they can find you online where you can
find me online amos e amos e youtube
facebook twitter all right man you'll
find me seriously you're a brave warrior
for all the right things and anything i
can do for you please let me know just
spread the word Ruben spread the word
and that's all I need